[Music]
there are certainly a lot of
considerations when you think you have
to be on top of your game from from the
beginning of the year in January all the
way through to the end of the season in
October for us I mean that's that's it
that's a long season you need to make
sure you're you're giving your body the
right kind of food and staying healthy
as well and once off from and I I
particularly enjoy from science and
sport is the multi VIP and the Omega 3
great ways of keeping you healthy you
know around the training sessions of the
diet is really important and getting the
carbs back in but then you know we're
all seasoned supplements like the
multivitamin and vitamin d3 as well in
the UK it's pretty dark and cold in the
winter so just keeping our health top up
during rehab you just kind of want to
tick off every box and make sure you
doing everything to the optimum and to
make up for what you can't eat you can
use supplements such as vitamin D and
motive it's a lot of megha 3 you know a
lot of things that you can often forget
about but certainly make a big
difference and in in the whole the
outside of things when you go in from
race to race and you're travelling
around these stuff is hard to sort of
have proper meals and things was always
good to top up with like multi-bit and
stuff and you know it's all the little
things really all together and hopefully
you know keep you healthy
you